hey everybody
yeah i'm vince allen and
here to talk to you about creating
natural simulations in a web browser
anyway my fiance made me promise i
wouldn't talk before the cat falls but
i believe that um a little bit about me
so i'm a software engineering manager at
spotify
and i live in brooklyn and i work in our
new york office
and you can get in touch with me at my
twitter handle vince allen events
you can also write me at vince
spotify.com
and all the code for the examples you're
going to see are at this github
address so there's just a little note
about the code
everything uses vanilla javascript css
html
there's no canvas there's no webgl svg
flash
java or like or even bitmaps
so in 2007
i was living near an apple store and a
week
before the iphone release there were
people in my neighborhood camped out to
hold
a place in line and this line you know
it went around the block and it was just
chairs and tents and so on and soon
after a friend of mine got an iphone
and i asked him you know what is so
great about this thing
that you'd spend a week outdoors and
he said he couldn't explain it but you
just have to use one
and soon after i got an iphone and i
i realized what he meant but i thought
he could have been
more specific i thought he could have
said you just have to hold one
so this was the first time i was holding
what we call now
a sensor rich device and i could see
the operating system mapping my physical
input
onto the ui in a way that realistically
mocked
this physical system so recently i went
to a talk
and it was a futurist and he was talking
about the future
and how there's there's gonna be a
post-pc world
where you know like our laptops and our
desktops are gonna be so smart and we're
gonna carry around these primary
computing devices in our pockets
and i don't dispute that view but i
don't think
large format interaction is going away
and i don't think
large format creativity is going away
in fact i think more than ever as
javascript developers we should be
thinking about
large format interaction we should be
thinking about it in terms of natural
interaction so for now you know the
desktop might go away
but it's a good place to experiment but
to make
desktop interactions as compelling
as what we're experiencing sensor rich
devices we need to figure out how to
combine
physical sensors so what do i mean by a
natural simulation
i have this definition it's a collection
of agents whose boundaries of autonomy
appear to be defined by natural forces
this is just a fancy way of saying you
have
a bunch of objects they have rules and
those rules make the system seem natural
but what i like about this definition
is it implies that we're observers and
we have a threshold
of believability so
what makes a system seem natural
instinctually we can differentiate
between something that's designed and
something that's natural
but if we're going to create natural
simulations in a web browser we need to
we need to identify exactly where this
threshold lies
because a web browser is not the easiest
place to try to do this we're going to
be resource constrained
so we don't want to do more than we
absolutely have to
so what point can we be confident that
we've crossed the line and the user will
accept
the simulation now i'm not the first
person
to think about this valentina
breitenberg was an italian
neuroscientist and in the 1960s he was
interested in
understanding how human beings developed
intelligence
and reasoning but instead of looking at
humans he looked at insects
and by examining simple brains he hoped
he could find the building blocks to our
cognitive evolution and in the 1970s he
wrote this book
and it describes a thought experiment
where he imagines
10 simple vehicles and these became
known as breitenberg vehicles
so each vehicle is equipped with sensors
that respond to specific input
as the vehicles progressed in his
imagination the sensors became
increasingly sophisticated
and at some point you the reader you
start accepting that if you observe this
behavior
in nature that you would accept that
it's part of the natural world
so let's look at some breitenberg
vehicles
so this is a very simple vehicle it has
two sensors
one is for heat and one is for cold it
speeds up around heat and it slows down
around things that are cold
so while this little creature here
doesn't seem all that intelligent if you
encountered this behavior
in nature you would probably say okay
this is something that's alive
but let's just tweak that rule a little
bit
instead of slowing down
around cold we're going to turn away
this is just a really simple refinement
to that rule
all right but immediately we get a sense
that this little guy understands his
environment he can navigate
and he can turn away at least and avoid
things he doesn't want to be around
all right what if we took the inverse of
this
what if we turned toward things that
stimulated us
and we blew them up
so already you know we've just taken the
inverse of the of a very simple rule
and we get something that looks even
more intelligent you know
not only does he understand his
environment but he's out to get things
in his environment then what if you
combine
a bunch of simple rules all right
in this one we have heat we have oxygen
we have food
and we have light and we're
we're attracted to food we're attracted
to oxygen
stimulated by heat and aggressive toward
light
this guy has a sense of values you know
if you if you let it run and you watch
it's almost like he has some type of
awareness of the different
of different tastes and i'd be willing
to bet if you saw
this type of behavior exhibited in
nature you would say
this is something it's natural
so when you stop looking at the
individual rules and you view their sum
as a system
you cross the line from designer to
observer
and that's the line that's the threshold
that we're looking for
so breitenberg recognized the odd
situation
that we put ourselves in as designers
you know we know that these are simple
rules
because we made the rules but we can't
help it at some point
we see the emergent behavior and not its
component parts
so with sensor rich devices i want to
cross the line in the other direction
you know i want to say that the iphone
the android phone is a breitenberg
vehicle
and it may not have wheels because it
doesn't need them
you know we're the wheels we carry them
around but it has the most important
part and that's the sensors
and when you think of them in this way a
collection
of sensors you can deconstruct these
rules that govern their systems
much like breitenberg was deconstructing
simple brains in search of answers to a
bigger
question what makes a system seem
natural
for me it's detail you know at some
point there's enough detail for us to
accept the system
but we need to know exactly what kind of
detail we're talking about so i want to
do a thought experiment
all right i want you to imagine that
you're james cameron
and you're going to make a summer
blockbuster but it's not going to be
avatar
it's going to be a movie about a guy
throwing a ball for a cat
all right but like avatar we're going to
do the whole thing computer generated
all this is going to be rendered and
it's going to be easy for the cat
and the guy right we can get a little
kitty motion capture suit and we can get
you know a motion capture suit for the
guy but you know the ball is going to be
kind of a problem right the ball
we can't just get a motion capture suit
for the ball we really need to simulate
and mimic the physics realistically
enough that it looks as real
as the people or the animal in the
motion capture suits so what what at a
high level are the details if we're
going to animate this ball we're going
to simulate it what are the details
we're looking for
at a high level we need variation right
so things
shouldn't always be the same i shouldn't
be throwing the ball the same way it
shouldn't be
it shouldn't float through the air the
same way
and randomness there should be a sense
of randomness so it should be hard to
predict where the ball is going to end
up it should be hard to predict
how it's going to bounce and that should
be balanced with
a sense of ordered complexity right so
while it's hard to predict exactly where
the ball is going to end up
at least we know it's going to be at the
end of the hall we know it's going to
bounce up off the carpet and so on
so let's get more specific like what do
we need to pay attention to what are the
significant things
that are that are driving where that
ball is going to end up at any point in
time
so there's acceleration there's this the
change in velocity of the ball as it
comes off my hand
and then from there's the earth's
gravity and then
if we talk about gravity we need to be
talking about mass if we're going to
talk about mass we need to talk about
friction
and then there's minute forces like the
wind coming from the ceiling fan
and then there's drag from like the air
density and it gets
much heavier around the litter box and
then there's resilience
borrow bouncing up off the carpet so the
point here is there's a lot of things
going on
and i want you to think of this system
as a mixing bowl where
you need to account for all of these
forces and we need to figure out we need
a mechanism
to do that that's really easy right
because we're in a web browser we're
doing
this javascript and we want this to be
super efficient
so how do we do it all right i'm going
to show you that in a minute
but i'm gonna be like bradenburg and i
wanna start simple
i wanna look at simple systems first and
see if there's anything we can learn
from them
right i loved these games i owned these
games i played them forever um but
there's there's something that should be
obvious you know everything's moving at
the same speed
you know when we talk about detail these
games are really fun they're great but
you know they kind of contrast what
we're used to seeing in the natural
world
the football doesn't go as fast as the
runner
so let's look at i created a couple of
studies just to talk about those high
level things that we're talking about
so this was a study in variation right
so we've got
a lot of variation we have variation in
color we have variation
in size but we've done something we've
mapped the size to mass
so the little guys you know they're not
going to jump as high and the big guys
are going to
jump super far and have a lot of
momentum
and then there's a sense of randomness
as well it's kind of hard to predict you
know where each individual one of these
guys is going to end up
but the same time we have some order
complexity we can generally tell
how they're going to move
and then there's a flocking simulation
all right so flocking
got a lot of variety here size color and
so on
but definitely randomness it's very hard
to predict
where exactly any one of these guys is
going to end up
but it's a flock it's going to
self-organize and so we're going to
balance that out with some ordered
complexity
and then i like to channel animal planet
because they differentiate between like
goofy animals and really cool animals
and i i think that like flying fish are
kind of the james bond of the animal
world
and i wanted to do something where
you had two environments you know in the
same simulation you have a primary and a
secondary
and just to get a sense of like drag and
moving from one to the other
all right so why is this difficult you
know to do
in a web browser
well first of all i mean the web
browsers were created basically
their first job was to present text and
beyond that
you know they're event driven they're
waiting for us to do things so that they
can respond and javascript is there to
help us do that as well
but there's also competing resources on
the system and you know
may have another browser open there's
other applications running on the
on the on the operating system but
there's also the network to continue
so you know rendering isn't necessarily
the first priority
and rendering a lot of things like that
isn't surely not
so this is basically me saying just not
meant to do this you know browser is not
a procedural drawing tool
it's it's not like processing or like
open frameworks so there's not of like
not a lot of convenience in terms of
rendering baked in there
so how are we going to do it all right
you guys probably already know the
request animation frame
we're going to use that we're going to
use hardware acceleration with some
hardware accelerated css properties but
we're going to use vector math
okay so when i talked about the mixing
bowl and adding of all the forces
vector math is going to let us do that
and i'll show you that in detail
in a second and then physical input for
me physical input is
is the one that gets us really across
the threshold when you can
map physical input to what you're seeing
on the screen
it's just all the more natural so let's
look at some code
so let's say we're trying to render that
ball right in the
in the guy throwing the ball for the cat
movie and
we want to start out really slow we're
just going to get the ball to drop from
the top of the browser
to the bottom so we're going to create a
vector and this is a vector class
and i talked about adding forces the
vector class has
an add method so let's look at vectors
really quick all right a vector i want
you to think of it
simply an offset it's the difference
between two points
what's cool about a vector is it also
implies
a magnitude right so i can say that
vector b here it's it's less
magnitude than it has less magnitude
than than vector a
because vector a is longer and
if i wanted to then sum the forces if
this was a system and let's say that
vector a was thermal energy coming off
the ground and vector b
was um you know wind blowing down to the
right what would that feel like to stand
there
and what would the combination of that
feel like and it would feel
like this all right so
imagine then it's pretty easy then to
pile on the forces
and you get the sum so that's what we're
going to do here
so when i create my ball class i'm going
to not have necessarily an x and y
coordinate i'm going to have a location
vector
a velocity vector and an acceleration
vector and one for gravity
and then we're going to use that in an
animation loop
and we're going to add gravity and it's
going to cascade
gravity goes to acceleration
acceleration to velocity and velocity to
location then we can finally draw the
ball right so what does this look like
all right it's not that bad that's about
20 lines of code
nothing special going on all right so
here's the cool part though so obviously
there's not enough detail in that
if we want to get to like that that
really cool
ultra realistic looking ball we're going
to need to add all those forces we
talked about and it's this easy
so we're going to add some wind and you
can see the wind vector is
moving slightly to the right and
we're going to add it to the
acceleration and this is what you get
you can probably guess what's going to
happen here we're going to blow down and
to the right
all right
all right so now we've had years to use
devices that map to our bodies
but by comparison you know a keyboard
and a mouse it feels a lot like
using a weird little hand to get it what
you want
so i want you to think about think about
the breitenberg vehicles we saw earlier
you know i'm talking
i'm saying that like an iphone is a
fancy breitbart vehicle right it has
sensors
and in fact has just enough sensors to
convince us that our interactions with
it are completely natural
so let's think about the desktop i mean
what can we do on the desktop
that's similar so large format inputs
right so
html5 has given us a lot of really cool
apis
that we can do things with we can access
the user's camera we get user media api
we can attach
game pads and analog controls with a
gamepad api
but there's three i'd like to focus on
some mouse acceleration
audio and gestures
all right i don't mean to criticize the
mouse um
at the time it was a step in the right
direction because you know at the time
we didn't have a weird little hand read
nothing right so but the experience of
course is mediated you can only
you can only click so hard but there is
something cool we can do with a mouse
and we can do it
we can do it right now so if you use
your mouse and you roll it around
right you're changing the location and
that's a velocity
and then you're likely changing the
velocity as well and that's an
acceleration
so we can apply an acceleration based on
how we're using the mouse
you know into a system so it's a matter
of getting a system
anyway web designers have recently
figured out a way to do this
and i think we've all seen
parallax sites right
they're everywhere spotify even has one
so i these are all the rage i mean you
see them everywhere and i think that
they're
popular not so much for how they look
but for how they feel to use
because this is the one opportunity we
have right now
where we get to apply a continuous
acceleration and things behave like a
natural system
you know items in the background feel
like they weigh more they're further
back
and so we use these and we get a
critical amount of detail and it feels
really good
so i had this idea i really wanted to
get to the heart of this i mean what if
you pushed it further what if
the scroll bar instead of mapping things
proportionately
you know it's location was proportional
to how far you use the scroll bar what
if you use the scroll bar
as a pedal and so it just applied an
acceleration into a system right
so i'll show you what i mean
so this would be like the traditional
way of doing some type of scroller right
you'd have a bunch of stuff
you'd scroll and it would move in the
opposite direction the scroll bar and
everything be nice and proportional
so what if we short circuited the scroll
bar
and now it's a pedal and if i let off of
it i don't get any acceleration but the
more
i pull on it the faster the acceleration
is and i can do this in both
directions you know all right so that's
kind of fun
and then to make it like a little more
interesting i can change up the colors
and
i can do different sizes and so on but
if we take all the things we learned
and we apply acceleration to velocity
and we map the size to some
mass let me get something that looks
like this
this is kind of fun
so the thing that's not cool about this
is that you know i've hijacked
a native ui element and and forced it to
do something it really wasn't
meant to do but remember what i talked
about with vectors all right and talking
about the mouse and location
so if i have a fixed point
and i have my mouse then i have a vector
and the further away i move from that
fixed point i can say is
a greater acceleration so what if i just
move further away from the middle of the
screen
and now i've got something that
doesn't even need a scroll bar
so i'm not saying that this is like what
you should do with your
your next website but
there is something conventional we can
do with this kind of thing
all right so we've all seen a horizontal
scroller right
and i can just take all the code that we
just saw and just flip it around
and take advantage of mouse proximity
and acceleration and friction and mass
and i get something
that is a gesture you know this when i
do this i'm pointing at what i want
i don't have scroll bars or anything
all right so we talked about mouse
acceleration let's talk about audio
all right so web audio api
combined with a get user media api it
allows us to
measure a stream of audio in terms of
its magnitude
across frequency spectrum and then i can
map that to divs that change and i could
talk and i've got something that looks
like this
so what if you combined
the microphone with a flocking
simulation
all right so here
if i take a tone generator that's on my
phone
here and i play it i can activate these
guys
let me get the volume i'll just back
away
so you can see i can pump them up freak
them out whatever
but what's kind of cool is i can then
switch and
anybody has a tone generator go nuts
so that's kind of fun but what's neat
about
that is all the in-betweens you know
so what if we have a bunch of attractors
i still have these guys
so now i'm implying a force with audio
a gravitational force and moving all my
fireflies around the screen all right
audio so what about gesture
so you guys have probably heard of this
thing
right it's the leap motion sensor plug
it into the usb port
and it will interpret or it'll detect
where your hand and fingers are
i've got one right here and
if i combine it with the man's free
you know a flocking simulation
you know all of a sudden this becomes
really fun
it would be fun with a mouse but it's a
lot more fun
just waving your hand
did you think this was going to come
back
so i said the mouse was a gesture why
not just use a gesture
all right i want to tell you a story
about a kid on a plane so recently i was
taking a flight
and i was seated next to a little girl
her mom was putting up the bags and she
gave her her phone
to pacifier while mom was doing whatever
it took to
get us all buckled in and
within seconds she had opened up the
phone navigated to a photo's application
and was able to find a video of herself
swinging on a swing
and this child was two years old and she
couldn't even talk
but she could use this phone as well as
i could use mine
you know when it hit me that we're born
knowing how to use these things and this
child may never use
a desktop pc or a laptop but she will
eventually use something other than an
iphone
likely a large format interface and as
javascript developers i believe that we
have the chance
to lay the groundwork for those types of
interactions so when you're creating
web ui on the desktop i challenge you to
think in terms of
natural interaction think about
breitenberg vehicles and and not the
component parts
but the system as a whole
so in other words i want to you i want
you to think about what makes an
interface appealing to
to this generation you know the
two-year-olds that don't have to learn
gestures because they already know them
they were born with them
so if you start from the perspective of
a natural system as you're prototyping
sandbox
you're going to often come up with
something that's more interesting than
approaching the design from the other
way around
but the good news is we've seen that the
threshold
is just not that far away i mean
instinctually we're tuned to look for
natural interactions
and when we find them we gravitate to
them and we adapt them
to talking about prototyping sandboxes
here's two
the only difference is the first one has
a lot of stuff but little documentation
the second one's simple but has a lot of
documentation so
and then i'd like to say that spotify is
thrilled to be a sponsor
at this conference and we're out here in
the hall
you can talk to us about a new spotify
feature called spotify connect
that lets you control and play music
across your phone tablet and speakers
we're also hiring so if you want to work
at
a cool company making cool things come
out and talk to us and we also have a
couple of code challenges you win a
couple of prizes
so that's me you can contact me i'd also
like to point out that i got a fair
amount of those physics formulas from
this book
nature of code by daniel schiffman it's
really good read it
and check out the code at the repo
thanks
you